welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were breaking down defending Jacob on
Apple TV normally with my videos are
trying to release them on the day that
the finale airs
however with defending Jacob I really
wanted to give the ending some time and
thought as a thing there's a lot going
on the show leaves so many unanswered
questions however if we look at the
subtext I think they provide a clear
direction as to what exactly happened in
the series throughout this video we'll
be going over the way things are left
and why they heavily imply one possible
outcome there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the show yet then I highly
recommend that you turn off now if you
enjoy this video then please drop a
thumbs up as it massively helps us out
and also subscribe to the channel for
videos like this every day without the
way thank you for clicking this let's
get into our breakdown of defending
Jacob
I want the truth
you can be a good man or you can be a
good father
okay so defending Jacob centers around
the barbers a family of three made up of
Andy played by Chris Evans Laurie played
by Michelle Dockery and Jacob played by
Jayden Martell Jacob is embroiled in a
murder trial after a boy who bullied him
is found dead and the story very much
focuses on his parents struggling over
whether he committed the crime or not
now from the off I will say that I do
think that Jacob did it another show is
deliberately ambiguous
there are several clues as to why this
is the case firstly is Jacobs attitude
in general throughout the show he's
portrayed as someone that's a
rule-breaker someone that isn't very
thoughtful and someone that will often
defy common sense in order to be seen a
certain way he deliberately returns to
social media after being told not to
post sick things on it and even write a
story about the murder itself that makes
LJ Simpsons if I did it look like a
shining example of what to do after
becoming a suspect Jacob was apparently
the first one that discovered Ben's body
and he tried to cover this up by not
reporting it so that he wouldn't get in
trouble I believe that he wasn't aware
of the forensics and that this was a lie
there is another suspect it does seem
strange that Jacob was first on the
scene if he had nothing to do with it
in addition to this and he finds a knife
that may or may not have been used as
the murder weapon whilst we learn that
this is a common knife it does add a lot
of weight when tied in with all of the
above as there was no real need for its
inclusion in the show if it wasn't a
point to one thing as the trial begins
it seems like Jacob is bank to rights
and the longer things go on the longer
that suspicion builds and Laurie's mind
but juxtaposing this and he believes his
son completely even as the boy was
growing up he refused to accept things
for how they were and always tried to
turn it so that there was no way his son
of family were capable of any wrongdoing
this ties into our view on the ending
and it's also laced throughout Andy's
childhood we learned that his father was
a very sick man and thus he's tried to
find the good in others rather than the
bad he defends his son till the end but
it looks like things are only going to
go one way that is a guilty verdict
however after a pedophile named Leonard
Pat
confesses to killing been before
seemingly committing suicide Jacob is
exonerated though there is a lot of
evidence that points towards Leonard
actually being behind Ben's death
including incriminating photographs on
his phone we actually learned that
Andy's father was behind it all
belly barber played by JK Simmons had
used an ally to force the confession and
thus its legitimacy is unable to be
determined so once more any actual proof
of Jacobs innocence can be brushed to
the side and in my eyes the fact that
this needed to be carried out is the
show hinting at us that Jacob got away
with it through nefarious means now this
is all evidence on the surface but what
did I mean about the subtext of the show
well if we take that Jacob did commit
the crime then that means that every one
of the barbers told a lie at some point
that broke the earth I'll discuss this
more as we get into the video but we do
need to kind of bring it up here so that
you pay attention to it Jacob lied about
what happened to Ben leading to the
family being shattered and he lied about
his father leading to the family being
broken apart and Lori lied about what
happened in the car crash which led to
Annie being left in the dark over
everything
thematically this show is very much
about families lying to one another and
whether they can live with that lie or
not Andy's father even tells him at one
point that he can either live with being
a good man or being a good father and
this choice of whether to protect Ally
or to protect the ones that we love is
shown in each of the characters
decisions now the cracks finally
reimaged during the family's trip to
Mexico in order to get away from all the
barbers take a vacation and on it Jacob
befriends a girl known as hub Conners
after a party hope goes missing and once
more suspicion turns to Jacob left at
breaking point and he reveals the truth
about his father and Laurie realizes
that potentially they may have covered
up one murder with another now hope does
turn up and harmed but everything is
already out in the open and Laurie's
mental state completely shatters Laurie
takes Jacob to get his hair cut but
during the ride internal per-mile gets
too much and she begins to question a
son with him eventually telling her that
he did kill Ben now this definitely
can't be taken as an absolute as the
character is clearly just saying
anything to get her to stop but it is
sure that he is well aware of what his
family think of
another thing that we know for definite
is that Andy is well aware of what his
wife tried to do even if he lies to
himself about it at the end and he finds
a photo album of Jacob's baby pictures
in the trash
and he correctly assumes that Laurie is
in the midst of doing something terrible
he tries to phone her several times and
she doesn't answer though I have seen
some people say that they don't know
whether Andy knows if Laurie crashed the
car on purpose him finding the baby
photos does clearly point to his
awareness of what she's done
now why Laurie did this is because I
actually believe that she possesses the
murder gene now I may be wrong on this
so let me know but from what I remember
they only really tested Jacob on Andy's
side of the family so Jacob may be
carrying some of the darker side of
Laurie's which would enable him to
commit the crime on Ben the show
concludes with Andy defending his wife
in trial and she manages to get away
with it even though deep down he knows
that she did try and kill her son Laurie
knows this too and clearly racked with
guilt she's been reading to him and has
said that she doesn't remember any of
the things that happen that day so once
more we can take a lot from this subtext
the fact that we know that Laurie did
indeed try and kill her son but got away
with it it's clearly at least to me
hinting that the showrunners want us to
look at Jacob and how similar things
happened with him Jacob was put on trial
and it was only two lies told by members
of his family that he was able to get
away from it so the fact that we know
that everything surrounding Laurie's
innocence is a lie also hints to us that
everything surrounding Jacobs is - and
he had the opportunity once more to be a
good man or a good husband slash father
and clearly he chose the latter to
protect his family throughout his life
Andy has ignored the truth much in the
same way that he has here and Laurie
lying reflects his lie which also
reflects Jacobs so whilst they don't
out-and-out say it if you look at the
similarities between the arcs at the
characters all go on they are all pretty
much identical now a big question is
will Jacob be able to forgive his mother
for what she did the other character is
in critical condition the doctors say
that there are some encouraging signs so
we can take from this that he will get
better you will have to live with
Laurie's lie as he is the only one
she knows the truth much in the same way
that she is the only one that actually
knows the truth about him because Laurie
has been willing to murder our own son
actually think that she will find more
common ground with him and they'll
realize that they have to protect each
other the show actually symbolizes this
in its final shot in several ways as we
see Andy return home he goes into Jacobs
room and sits in the dock metaphorically
showing that out of the whole family he
is the one that's been left in the dark
over everything whilst Laurie and Jacob
both know the truth about one another on
the whole the show really symbolizes not
only the darkness within the community
but darkness within the families
themselves people that knew serial
killers often remark on how you would
never suspect it and it shows that it's
almost impossible to tell if someone has
a dark side but that these aspects of
society do indeed exist Jacob was
seemingly a good kid but he held a
sinister side which was showcased in his
writing and also the axe that we believe
he carried out Laurie to add this even
though on the surface she seemed fine
Andy is the only one that actually
didn't carry out a dark act and though
he did lie he didn't go to the extremes
that we know Laurie did and that Jacob
possibly could have this is what the
final shot symbolizes to me I love how
it's just
Andy sat in the darkness surrounded by
it as he's the only one who's not turned
to it himself
cinematography often carries hidden
meanings and I believe that this final
shot is hinting at him being the only
truly innocent one in the family so
whilst the show is deliberately set up
to not tell us a definite I think the
subtext is laced throughout in which we
can only draw one conclusion firstly is
the orgy of evidence that surrounds
Jacob that pits him at the scene of the
crime gives him the murder weapon motive
and more secondly is the fact we see
firsthand how someone is able to get
away with a crime because the rest of
the family is willing to cover for them
much in the same way that Billy did for
Jacob thirdly is the fact that the show
ends on Andy sat in the darkness still
unsure about what's going on and he is
not with the other members of his family
due to them both attempting horrendous
things I think the hints are all there
and whilst even I can't say for definite
when you look at how the show is built
the matically
the event
that happen it and the way that it ends
we can only really take it one way and
that is that Leonard did it I got ya cut
you in the end powers it was Jake it was
definitely Jacob now obviously I'd loved
hear your thoughts on our interpretation
and whether you agree or not comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out our
breakdown of snowpiercer which is gonna
be linked at the end you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat us after the
show either follow us at heavy spoilers
or click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people us subscribe
to the channel and this month he can win
the Marvel phase to report to box set
and all you have to do is comment on a
video and make sure you subscribe with
notifications on the more video Izzy
comment on the more you've a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of June and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck that
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace